Speaker 1: Welcome everybody. I want to
start today with a foreign policy situation
that is quickly building, and I want to
highlight some comments that were made,
which I think are sort of the epitome of
the false simplification of the situation
in Russia and Ukraine. Now the context here
is we have a genuinely concerning escalation
in terms of Russian aggression or threatened
aggression, implied aggression towards Ukraine.
I think we still don't really know Vladimir
Putin's true intentions. On the one side,
once we consider 130000 Russian troops massing
at the Ukrainian border with significant military
equipment and an arsenal of various weapons. We
say, well, Putin's clearly planning to invade
and try to take Ukraine. The other side would be
Putin has no intention whatsoever of invading,
and this is all either sort of a let's see
what happened sort of thing. Or even further,
some say this is the logical reaction from Russia
to the hostilities from Ukraine and NATO's allies,
saying maybe, maybe, maybe Ukraine will at some
point become part of NATO's, which would be very
much not to Vladimir Putin's advantage now. I
want to highlight some comments made by former.
I know it's weird to say former Democratic
Congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard, and a lot of you
will say that she's almost exclusively appearing
on Fox and giving pretty reactionary takes. What
she she was a Democrat when she was in the
House of Representatives. I'm just telling it
to you like it is. And what Tulsi Gabbard says to
Tucker Carlson is really the epitome of the false
simplification that a certain wing. And again,
I don't even want to call it a wing of the left
because it's what what views of hers are
now really left? But it doesn't matter.
This is a view on Russia, Ukraine that is
really the epitome of the Russians, the victim,
not the aggressor. And the U.S. is primarily the
bad actor perspective. And Tulsi also takes it as
an opportunity not only generally to criticize the
United States, but also to criticize Joe Biden.
And here's her view on how we de-escalate the
Russia Ukraine situation. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Well, first of all, Biden, President
Biden could end this crisis and prevent a war
with Russia by doing something very simple,
guaranteeing that Ukraine will not become a
member of NATO because if Ukraine became a member
of NATO, that would put U.S. and NATO troops
directly on the doorstep of Russia, which, as
Putin has laid out, would undermine their national
security interests. The reality is that it is
highly, highly unlikely that Ukraine will ever
become a member of NATO anyway. So the question
is why doesn't President Biden and NATO leaders
actually just say that you can guarantee it?
Speaker 1: Tucker loves it. This is a this take
is perfect for Fox News. As you can see now
there's there's two major problems with this and
the reason I'm using tools. These comments as an
on ramp to this is because there's lots of people
who are saying, you know, we're goading the West
is goading Ukraine. I'm sorry. The West is goading
Russia by maybe flirting with the possibility
that Ukraine could become part of Naito,
and many of them say a promise was made that that
would never be the case. So, Joe, it's Joe Biden.
So there's two issues here. First of all, is the
major issue of why can't we just say the best way
to prevent an escalation is for the aggressor to
stop their aggression? OK. I don't want war with
Russia. I don't want to attack Russia. I'm not an
imperialist. I'm not a warmonger. I'm not any of
those things. But we have to be able to say that's
the aggressor. And the aggressive action here
is not that Ukraine joining NATO's hasn't been
ruled out. Well, let's look at the simplest
and most direct form of aggression, which is what
Putin is doing with troops at the border. We just
have to be able to say what things are. That's
number one. So it's crazy to think, you know,
Tulsi was a Democratic candidate and that she
actually had the support of a few percent of
the Democratic primary electorate. And they fell
for it and they supported her. And these are these
are her takes. But let's dig in a little more
into this Naito piece. There's lots of people
like Tulsi and others who sometimes kind of
pretend to be on the left, but they're really
apologists for authoritarians. And one of the
things they love to repeat about Russia Ukraine
is that there was a promise made that Naito
would stop expansion, and they would rule
that Ukraine would. There was a promise Ukraine
will never be part of Naito. And the real source
of aggression is starting to toy. With Ukraine
being part of Naito. This is all based on a lie.
There is no such promise, and because this
is so prevalent in these discussions where
Russia ends up being defended at the core of
this is a lie. Such a promise, the promise that
Ukraine would never join Naito was initially
proposed verbally by the German and U.S. foreign
ministries, but it was later rescinded by the
heads of government. But Bush and Kohl at the
time. And it was never put on the table again, so
there is no such promise that has been codified.
And why does something so obscure matter? It
matters because it underlines the perspective
of many of these people on the situation at
the time. Hans Dietrich Genscher of Germany
said it's certain Naito will never have troops
on East German soil and some other promises
that were made there. But the statement
was walked back. It was walked back, and
no such promises were ever codified in any way. It
keeps getting repeated. Naito broke its promise.
Naito is breaking its promise. Naito would break
its promise. The U.S. is breaking its promise.
There is no such promise. And so the focus should
be on the aggressors and the aggressors. Here
are Putin and Russia. Bigger picture Ukraine is
a sovereign nation. Russia doesn't get to say
we can legitimately be aggressive because
Ukraine wants to join NATO, if that's the
case. And so there are some bad faith actors.
Tulsi Gabbard is one of them who have sort of
manipulated and molded the situation with lies by
omission and the like to create this completely
false narrative. And unfortunately, there are
there are some people on the left that are falling
for it. So we're going to continue trying to make
clear what really should be very, very clear.